academy-award
I still can't believe I'm standing here
it's a dream long time ago every year
when I watch Oscar with my dear some
time with my mom my dear I would say son
you get so many movie out a war in the
world when you get one of this then I
just look at my day
ha ha ha there I only me make comedy
action movies many years later accompany
Hollywood meeting with some big studio
director my friend's house Stallone's
house there was 23 years ago I see these
little things in his house I touched a
history as melded I believe still have
my finger prints in the Cuban then I
talk to myself I really want one
finally share it cause I'm saying are
you sure after 56 years film industry
making more than 200 films I bring so
many bones finally this is mine
I want to I want to thank you
Hong Kong incredible City my hometown my
hood who make me China my country proud
to be Chinese Thank You Hollywood for
all those years teach me so many things
and also make me a little bit famous and
I thank you my my family my wife Joanne
my son JC especial Jackie Chan Stan team
this year to check each instant him 40
years anniversary and all the friends
thank you thank you from the bottom of
my heart and ladies and gentlemen and
also the Skinnygirl gas and Academy
motion picture are in science thank you
thank you thank you and I want to thank
you
who should I thank you and forget and I
still have some dialogue I forget when I
say should I say I don't know I just is
honored to be here it's my honor thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
last not least million thanks to all my
friends fans around the world because
you I couldn't have a reason continue to
make movies jumping a window kicking and
punch you keep breaking my bone thank
you so much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]